from Surprise ghosts to vengeful spouses
and a whole lot of doppelgangers these
movies delivered the most shocking twist
we've ever seen this goes without saying
but spoilers ahead it's t two years
after terrifying audiences with get out
Jordan Peele frightened everyone again
with us a freakish horror film with a
genuinely shocking ending the film opens
in 1986 when a young Adelaide Thomas
wanders into a Hall of Mirrors and meets
her diabolical doppelganger Flash
Forward a couple of decades an adult
adelade is confronting her evil twin yet
again only this time the doppelganger
known as red has brought an army of
scissor wielding clones up from their
underground layer with each assigned to
kill their real world counterpart
throughout the film Adelaide and her
family managed to outwit and defeat
their doubles and in the climactic
sequence our hero finally confronts her
Twisted doppelganger but in a stunning
flashback we suddenly realized we might
be rooting for the wrong person as it
turns out Adelaide is actually the
grinning Doppelganger from the opening
scene when she encountered the real
Adelaide in the fun house she strangled
the girl unconscious dragged her into an
underworld of mute monsters and then
took the real adela's place place so
Adelaide is really red and red is the
real Adelaide and this whole creepy
scheme has been about getting revenge
for having her life taken away
ultimately The Twist works as commentary
on issues like privilege and nature
versus nurture but in the moment all you
can really think about is picking your
jaw up off the floor the twist ending of
The Usual Suspects is almost more famous
than the movie itself the entire film is
narrated by verbal Kint sole survivor of
a heist gone wrong verbal is a timid
Thug who suffers from cerebral paly and
as he's being interrogated by Customs
agent Dave CP verbal spins a story of
how he and his crew were drafted by the
world's most notorious criminal an
underworld Boogeyman named Kaiser S as
verbal tells this crazy story coin
suspects verbal BFF Dean Keaton was
secretly so and that he betrayed all his
buddies during their bloody Caper
convinced he solve the crime he lets
verbal walk and takes a minute to Rebel
in his detective skills and that's when
he notices the bulletin board shocked
kuin realizes that verbal story was
complete nonsense and that he assembled
his wild tale by pulling keywords and
details from the papers and wanted
posters tacked on the wall and as kujin
figures out he let a guilty man walk
free we see verbal Kent morphing into a
new man his limp disappears his gnarled
hand straightens out and he starts
walking with the confidence of a crook
who beat the system for the millionth
time this little nobody is actually
Kaiser s and then like that he's gone it
might be the greatest trick of movies
ever pulled and it's a kind of twist
that will make you drop your coffee mug
in shock even with hits like memories of
murder and snow piercer already under
his belt bong Jun ho stunned audiences
with parasite a subtle examination of
the relationship between one family that
has nothing the Kims and another that
has everything the parks after a friend
of the young KIU invites him to lie his
way into the wealthy Park home to act as
a tutor KIU goes one step further by
getting his entire family jobs this
quickly spins a web of deception that we
sense won't end well but it's a
carefully calculated deterioration of
everyone's lives that makes the film The
Wild rde it is Parasite is full of
commentary on the toxicity of the super
rich but the societal con that sees
underprivileged people fighting each
other for scraps is a glue that holds
the whole mess together when the Kims
begin feeling confident in the park
family's dependency they have an
audacious living room Gathering while
the family is away while we expect them
to be found out by the parks what
actually happens is even more jarring
moong Guan whose life they ruined by
getting her fired to protect their own
deceit returns begging to be let inside
we discovered she's been keeping her
husband in the basement of the park
family home for years unknown to the
parks this is just one of the
developments that signifies imminent
disaster for all and is one of the most
surprising moments in a film full of
reveals Mary and crane yearns to settle
down with her boyfriend Sam but his
debts are preventing them from finding
happiness together stealing the money he
needs from her job and going on the lamb
she's forced to take overnight Refuge at
the isolated bait's Motel there she
meets what she assumes to be an overall
harmless weirdo named Norman Bates who
shows her to her room sadly Maran has
caught the attention of his mother Norma
Marian will never leave the hotel while
Norman is forced to cover for his
mother's crimes psycho is easily one of
director Alfred Hitchcock's most
notorious Thrillers and even decades
later it's easy to see why the best
remembered for its more shocking scenes
those only succeed due to the incredible
tension building of the quieter moments
sure it's terrifying that women are
going missing at this mysterious Hotel
on a lonely highway but relaxed moments
where Norman Bates casually explains his
interest in Taxidermy are arguably more
frightening if only in retrospect still
psycho has two major twists with the
first being the surprise death of Mary
in the film's point of view character
within the first half hour additionally
the reveal that Norman's mother has been
dead all along and that Norman is
channeling her in his own mind is still
scary today Friday the 13th has a unique
place in film history being an
independent production that gained Major
Distribution at a time when that was
essentially unheard of not only spawning
a huge franchise in its own right but
also helping to Herald a new era of
slashers Friday the 13th is sometimes
referred to as a surface level response
to Halloween but there's a fair amount
of social commentary at play in The
Script though it would be a stretch to
call it nuanced the lack of
accountability at summer camps during
the time is a catalyst for much of what
occurs as is the cruelty and neglect
towards a disabled boy named Jason
Vorhees that it allows they were told
that Jason drowned in the leg the heavy
boots and bulky jacket of the massed
killer lead us to believe that he
continues to stalk the campgrounds
killing the new Teen counselors however
it turns out that Pamela Vorhees is in
fact the killer seeking Vengeance for
her son's horrible death even if this is
seldom mentioned in the franchise's many
sequels it is nonetheless a part of
Horror history name the killer in Friday
the 13th Jason Jason Jason I'm sorry
that's the wrong answer ears down the
line This twist is used as a gacha in
the opening sequence of scream in which
the doomed Casey Becker desperately
insists that the killer in Friday the
13th was Jason only to be rudely
corrected that it was in fact Mrs
Vorhees in the first film in Miguel's
Home music is banned due to his
great-grandmother Elda having been
abandoned by a wward musician many years
before the daughter of this trist Coco
is Miguel's elderly grandmother her life
having been in many ways decided by her
father's disappearance Miguel is a
natural knack for music but his
responsibility to his family waste
heavily upon Him idolizing the musician
Ernesto De La Cruz Miguel becomes
convinced that Ernesto was his
great-grandfather this leads Miguel to
announce his intention to become a
musician but his grandmother wrecks his
guitar obtaining Ernesto's mythical
guitar Miguel gains the ability to
converse with his dead relatives Miguel
forms an alliance with a ghost named
Hector renouncing His
great-grandmother's blessings in favor
of finding Ernesto though hernesto
initially welcomes Miguel's family his
deceptions are soon revealed indeed
Hector was actually Miguel's
great-grandfather all along and he only
abandoned his family because he was
poisoned to death by his jealous musical
partner Ernesto naturally this leads to
a bit sweet conclusion with Hector
finally honored for his musical genius
and reunited with Elda and Coco albeit
in the Land of the Dead the family ends
the ban against music allowing Miguel to
finally pursue his dream and honor his
family Chuck pollen's novel Fight Club
inspired one of the best loved cult
classics of the last 25 years with a
1999 movie version starring Edward
Norton as a narrator disillusioned with
the mundanity of his life the more
flamboyant Tyler Duran appears to Echo
his own long-held criticisms against his
capitalist lifestyle giving a mouthpiece
to his anger
together they start Fight Club which is
exactly what it sounds like I'm messing
a cult-like following of men Desperately
Seeking something to lash out at it's a
pretty short road to extreme criminal
behavior and increasingly bizarre acts
of vandalism as our narrator realizes
that he's completely losing control to
Tyler's chaotic vision for their Project
Mayhem Duran's girlfriend Mara drops the
Bomb by calling him Tyler that's right
the narrator was actually Tyler Duran
all along though he makes hared attempts
at preventing Duran's plan of erasing
dead by bombing buildings even he is
unable to stop project Mayhem on the
plus side he seems to expel the dirt and
presence from his mind although the film
wraps on a fairly ambiguous note in that
regard either way he realizes what a
jerk he's been to Marlo and together
they watch the buildings fall to the
tune of the Pixies where is my mind
taking place in what was then the
farflung futuristic year of 2022 soent
green has a Twist so well known that
even if you haven't seen the film
chances are that you know its most
famous line at first we're only told
that soent is a cheap nutritious food
staple that comes in several flavorful
varieties such as soilent red red
soilent yellow and the new soilent green
The Narrative predicts a world on the
verge of climate collapse that we assure
you in no way resembles the actual Earth
of 20122 detective Robert Thorne is
investigating the murder of a soilent
board member who appears to have been
assassinated spoiler alert it really
does not work out great for him thoren's
elderly friend Soul Roth discovers that
soilent green once made of Plankton is
no longer possible to manufacture due to
the effect of pollution and global
warming on the ocean naturally the
soilent board opts for the next best
thing to plank in human corpses Roth
dies by a assisted suicide using his
last words to tell Thorn the truth this
leads to the famous final scene silent
green is
people it's easy to take for granted
what a huge deal saw was for horror fans
when it was first released this is due
in no small part to the twist ending but
the setup is where all the magic happens
it opens on a photographer named Adam
and a doctor named Gordon each chained
pipes in a room with a dead body lying
fa down between them each has a micro
cassette in their pockets with Adams
urging him to survive while Gordon
orders him to kill Adam by 6:00 this
leads Gordon to realize that they are in
the hands of the so-called jigsaw killer
known for kidnapping victims and forcing
them to participate in elaborate games
it turns out that Gordon is a major
suspect in the jigsaw case having
attracted the attention of detective tap
who sent Adam to spy on him this leads
to a series of reveals that has the
audience believing that just about every
character in the film could possibly be
the real jigsaw at one point or another
ultimately A desperate Gordon freeze
himself but only by sawing off his own
foot this in turn comes with the
realization that they got everything
about jigsaw true identity wrong Adam
looks on in horror as the corpse on the
floor Rises to its feet revealing
himself to be Gordon's patient John
Kramer the real
chicksaw game
over this Sleek Neo Noir takes a dive
back into 1950s America introducing us
to detective Teddy Daniels and his new
partner Chuck together they are
investigating a psychiatric Institute
located on you guess it shudder Island
an inmate Rachel solando who has drowned
her three children has gone missing and
the hospital staff is is unhelpful
Daniels becomes convinced that everyone
on the grounds is part of a plot to
misdirect the investigation including
Chuck this is all made worse by his
constant migraines and blackouts
possibly caused by his memories of
serving in the military and witnessing
the atrocities at DACA When Rachel
solando reappears she asserts that she's
actually a psychiatrist working to
develop mind control meanwhile senior
psychiatrist collie tells Daniels that
he never arrived with a partner at all
eventually the man we knew as Chuck
introduces himself as another doctor at
the facility Dr Shian informing us that
Daniels is actually Andrew a patient
under their care after Andrew failed to
seek treatment for his manic depressive
wife Dolores she killed their children
and he killed her this left him with
overwhelming guilt and his delusions
have as such made him a prime candidate
for lobotomization yet even as shean
gives the order he is left to wonder how
powerful Andrew's delusions truly are as
he calls him by the name Teddy and
Andrew does not
respond what are you
thinking how are you
feeling what have we done to each other
if ever there was a film that is more a
cascading series of twists and a linear
narrative story that would be gone girl
but it starts with a basic murder
mystery when his wife Amy goes missing
Nick's General disinterest in the
subject raises red flags for pretty much
everyone he and Amy had an unhappy Union
after relocating from New York to
smalltown Missouri which in turn saw him
beginning an affair with a student named
Andy things just get Messier from there
with a scavenger hunt leading
authorities to discover a partially
burned diary in which Amy discloses her
apparent fear of Nick we soon find out
however that Amy has been alive all this
time and is simply hiding out in the
Ozarks getting her kicks by messing with
everyone from afar considering that we
were pretty ready to say goodbye to Nick
for killing his wife this is a stunning
moment but with Amy the twists Never End
appas xes are caught in her Crossfire as
is an increasingly lost Nick though he
and his allies get to the bottom of
Amy's Revenge plot eventually they are
never able to prove anything and are all
well aware of her status as a master
manipulator in the end Nick is powerless
to escape her even as her crimes
escalate he ultimately agrees to stay
with her and the two of them face the
Press together exactly as Amy
wants Barbarian writer and director Zack
creger apparently loves twist so much
that he decided to make a whole movie of
them The Story begins with the nightmare
scenario of hero Tess showing up to an
Airbnb only to discover that a stranger
named Keith is already staying there
this makes it seem like we're in for a
fairly straightforward horror movie yet
the danger that Keith might pose goes on
the back burner as Tess discovers a
literal torture dungeon downstairs when
Keith is brutally killed by a naked
screaming woman covered in Grime it's
clear that Barbarian is not going to
follow the story we expected to the
story flips over to the homeowner an
actor named AJ whose career is derailed
when his co-star comes forward with
sexual assault allegations though he
denies this it's clear that he did
something very wrong returning to his
property in hopes of rebuilding he
comically fails to see the danger is in
and ends up trapped in the basement with
Tess taking a trip back in time we see
that the standard stoic conservative man
who previously owned the house still
lives in the tunnels below he spent
decades dragging women into the basement
to torture them with a naked woman being
his offspring there are actually still
more twist to this film but we're
running out of breath so we'll just say
that Barbarian is a great reason to skip
the ABS and book a hotel room Samuel
Bell is hanging out on the moon alone
operating in a Mining facility with the
assistance of a very anthropomorphized
AI named Gertie almost right off the bat
Sam experiences delusions and nearly
dies when he crashes his lunar rover
however he has no memories of this and
begins to suspect that Gertie is
deceiving him this is correct and he
discovers a doppelganger of himself at
the side of the crash dragging his other
self back to the base he confronts
Gertie who explains that they are
actually both clones though they are
there to keep the station functional
their occasional deaths are expected by
the company which has granted Gertie the
freedom to awaken new clones at will
this is a pretty huge twist in and of
itself but the film is not done with us
yet the company the Sams work for has
intentionally jammed signals to prevent
him from ever successfully calling for
help meaning he is trapped there
indefinitely the two Sams work together
to create an escape plan with the older
version agreeing to stay behind as the
younger escapes back to Earth though
he's able to expose the company that
doomed him this ends on a fairly
Bittersweet note for Sam whose wife wife
died on Earth several years before and
whose other selves begin to die around
their third year of Life director HRI
George kuso has often been referred to
as the French Hitchcock which should
tell you what to expect from his most
famous films a Pioneer in the realm of
the Thriller luo's Masterwork may very
well be La diabi Christina a Venezuelan
immigrant is the owner of a troubled
boarding school that's run by her
tyrannical husband Michelle de lasal
Christina suffers from a heart condition
that leaves her physically somewhat
frail making it difficult for her to
manage either with or without her
husband enter Nicole a teacher with whom
Michelle is having an affair who bonds
with Christina due to their Mutual abuse
at his hands together they decide that
the only way to rid themselves of
Michelle is to kill him however when his
body goes missing Christina begins to
suspect that Michelle is still alive
haunting the grounds and waiting for the
perfect moment to strike this ends in a
startling conclusion as we realize that
Christina's Ally Nicole never truly
intended to kill Michelle indeed they
wanted to shot Christina into a fatal
heart attack which is just what happens
when Michelle comes lumbering Tor her
one night this doesn't work out for an
Nicole and Michelle either but it's
impossible not to feel Christina's
Horror in her last moments the finale
tells us that it's possible that
Christina has survived or is at least
haunting the school grounds
herself writer director Frank darot
waited many years for the chance to
adapt Stephen King's The Mist a Nolla
about a town in Maine in which the
residents are suddenly surrounded by an
all-encompassing fog while this is
ostensibly a simple Creature Feature
complete with tentacled monsters lurking
in the Mist that pick off residents at
random the behavior of Everyday People
in a crisis may be the true horror they
even in his Sun Billy are forced to take
shelter with other Town's people in a
supermarket as they attempt to cope with
the apparent apocalypse although not
everyone wants to work together to
survive darmont organizes an excellent
ensemble cast to deliver a message
decidedly more upsetting than even the
original Stephen King ending in fact
that ending is exactly where the movie's
major twist comes in when David and some
of the other residents choose to take
their own lives rather than face the
of the monsters lurking outside he
kills the others including his child and
prepares to walk into the Mist to meet
his fate but almost immediately the Mist
dis dissipates as a military arrives and
takes care of the threat with little
problem realizing that he's killed his
friends and loved ones for absolutely no
reason David screams in despair perhaps
joined by some members of the
[Music]
audience ight Shyamalan is well known
for his twists from the six cents to the
village and Beyond one of his most
precisely delivered shocks is in the
film unbreakable which introduces us to
a take on superheroes and Trench in
day-to-day realism point of view
character David is traumatized reeling
due to being left as the sole survivor
of horrific train derailment that killed
131 other passengers soon he meets
Elijah price known for his physical
Frailty who posits that David has
superpowers and is as such the hero of
the story rather than dining at Cape and
tights David insists that he is no hero
more true to life his attempts at crime
fighting are messy and questionable
leaving him in the midst of an
existential crisis as he tries to cope
with his new reality when he uses his
powers of intuitional Price He is
stunned to find that the other man has
actually orchestrated a number of
apparently accidental tragedies
including the train wreck that uncovered
David's Powers using his own theories of
superheroes through much of the film to
inspire David we are stunned to realize
that price is actually a super villain
taking on the moniker Mr glass he views
David as his natural opposite and seen
through the lens of comic book
morality shades of classic ghost stories
like the turn of the screw can be found
in writer director Alejandra am menab
Bar's Eerie 2001 Chiller the others
Nicole Kidman stars as Grace Stewart who
lives in a vast mansion with her two
young children in the aftermath of World
War II because the kids are painfully
sensitive to light Grace keeps the house
in darkness throughout the day that
makes it the perfect stomping ground for
what appears to be the spirits of a
family who lived in the house previously
although it appears that these servants
who dutifully tend to Grace and the
children may actually be dead as well I
see dead people The Twist coming just 2
years after the Sixth Sense is that it's
Grace and her children who are deceased
a despairing Grace smothered the
children and took her own life when she
learned that her husband was killed in
the war the others they're seen are
actually the living family that has
bought the house following the tragedy
but even though the ghostly housekeeper
Mrs Mills warns Grace that she'll have
to learn to get along with the next
occupants of the house Grace doesn't
seem quite ready to make nice as the
others comes to its haunting
close in the landmarked 1968 sci-fi film
Planet of the Apes Charlton hon stars as
Taylor an astronaut who joins a deep
space mission not to just explore the
Galaxy but to get away from the fellow
humans he's come to despise a Time Warp
sends Taylor and his crew barreling
2,000 years into the future and they
crash land on a planet where
evolutionist flipped intelligent talking
apes are the dominant species and humans
are mute Savages forced to defend his
species and aided by sympathetic
chimpanzees who discover evidence of
human civilization that existed before
that of the Apes Taylor escapes death at
the hands of the Sinister Dr Zas only to
have his worst fears confirmed he's been
on Earth all along with the Apes
descending after humankind wiped itself
out in a nuclear war the image of hon
falling to his knees in front of a half
buried Statue of Liberty is one of the
most powerful in cinematic history and
is easily one of its greatest twist
endings God damn you all the
hell